- "The Art of Bill Cosby,"
"McCarthy Called
Trump/What Did Trump Said,"
"Tristan Threatens Death
"to Lamar on Instagram, #Kardashian."
These are all topic ideas
for this particular channel
that an AI robot says I should make.
I would have great success
making any of those videos.
Unfortunately, most of those
titles are complete nonsense.
And to the extent they're not nonsense,
I'm not going to be making
any of those videos.
That being said, I think
it's worthwhile going through
some of these titles because
A, they're hilarious,
and B, some of them
actually aren't that bad.
For background purposes,
I subscribe to a YouTube
tool called vidIQ.
It's pretty good. I like it.
And it just has a new feature,
and this is not sponsored,
where they come up with
ideas for my channel
using AI technology.
Now, my friend Tom Scott did a whole video
about using the AI technology GPT-3
to come up with topic
ideas for his channel,
and he even did a follow-up
where he used that technology
with a bunch of other YouTubers.
He didn't ask me to be in that video,
and I'm definitely not upset about that.
(melancholy instrumental music)
But now that I think I have access
to probably the same technology,
let's use it on the channel
and take a look at the videos
that the AI robots say I should make.
Now, I'm not gonna be
making any of these videos,
so if you are a YouTube lawyer
who is looking for ideas,
please take these ideas.
I'd love to see them.
I'm looking at you,
Richard Hoeg, Eve Cornwell,
and Attorney Tom.
Please use any of these ideas.
I think it'd be hilarious.
So let me explain why
I'm not going to make
any of these videos.
(upbeat instrumental music)
The first topic is,
"Donald Trump and the GOP."
I mean, that one's just
too obvious, right?
I mean, Donald Trump is the GOP.
And frankly, on this channel,
I try not to do overtly political content
unless there is some legal angle to it.
So, I don't think there's
a legal angle there.
(upbeat instrumental music)
"President Trump versus Kamala Harris."
That'd be interesting.
I think everyone would like
to see that cage match,
but there's no real legal issue there.
All of the talk of the
25th Amendment is now over,
so I don't think there's
any reason for LegalEagle
to do a President Trump
versus Kamala Harris video.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And then we have, "Afghanistan,
Trump versus social media,
"Sha'Carri Richardson."
Man, that could be a
really interesting video
putting Afghanistan and Trump on one side,
and social media and Sha'Carri
Richardson on the other.
If you don't know, Sha'Carri Richardson
is the female U.S. athlete.
She's a runner.
She was, I think,
disqualified from the Olympics
because she tested positive for marijuana.
Ah boy. I could probably come
up with some legal angle.
I mean, obviously, in this tag team match
you have Trump versus social media,
so it's all about Section 230.
But then Afghanistan and
Sha'Carri Richardson,
I don't see any reason
why they would be at odds
with each other, so this
one probably doesn't work.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Then we have, frankly, a
fantastic idea for a video.
It has only one problem.
Let's see if you can
figure out what that is.
And the topic idea is,
"Bill Cosby Gets the Chair."
The problem is there's no universe
in which Bill Cosby is
going to get the chair.
He was released from prison.
You know how I would do...
Here's... (chuckles)
If I did it, here's how I would do it.
I would do an alternate universe
where I would explain how all of the laws
would need to be different
in order for Bill Cosby
to actually get the chair.
That's how I would do that video.
That could be really interesting.
Yeah, I'll have to think about that one.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Then we have actually another
great idea for a video,
"Part Two: Britney Spears Documentary."
This is great because I don't
even have to make part one;
I just go straight to part two.
Part one's gonna be boring anyway.
It's really the part two
of the Britney documentary
that it really gets good.
So that's a great idea.
I just don't really have time
to do an entire documentary
about Britney Spears.
But I do like the idea of
just completely skipping over
part one and going straight to part two.
(upbeat instrumental music)
"Donald Trump: Racist in Chief."
I mean, there's no legal video there.
It's also a little too
on the nose, I think.
And, like it or not,
simply saying racist things isn't illegal.
I mean, I guess you could
do a survey of the laws
that Donald Trump wanted to pass
or the executive orders that he passed
and you could make a
judgment call on that.
But you know, frankly, I
think we're all a little tired
of talking about the
former guy at this point.
(upbeat instrumental music)
So then we have, "Sha'Carri
Richardson Denied Participation
"in the Olympics,"
and, "Sha'Carri Richardson
Is Out of the Olympics."
Both great topics, no
real legal issue there.
If the Olympic Committee
wants to make a law
about precluding people
who have tested positive
for marijuana from
participating in the Olympics,
they can make that rule.
It's not an American law.
Nothing really for me to talk about there.
Yes, marijuana laws in general are stupid.
That's not my perspective as a lawyer.
That's just my perspective as
a human being with a heart,
which often is at odds with
my perspective as a lawyer
who, you know, is not
allowed professionally
to have a heart.
But I don't think there's
really anything there
for me to talk about, on
this channel at least.
Someone should make that video though.
(upbeat instrumental music)
"Bill Cosby Needs to Be
in Jail: Rant Video."
Eh, you know, frankly, I see the reasons
why Bill Cosby is not in jail anymore.
There are reasonable
Fifth Amendment arguments
for why he was let out of jail.
A lot of people disagree with me.
My friends over at Opening Arguments
think that Bill Cosby should be in jail.
And if they had more of
a presence on YouTube,
they could totally make that,
"Bill Cosby Should Be in Jail" rant video.
They absolutely should.
But they're happy just to do a podcast.
So, you know, take that, Andrew.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And then we have a video
that I kind of already did.
"Britney Spears Speaks Out in Court,
"Asks to End Conservatorship."
I did an entire video on the
Britney Spears conservatorship.
I will probably do another video
when the conservatorship
issue reaches a head.
In fact, there was a big news article
that she was able to finally hire
her own attorney of her choice.
That's big news.
And this whole saga is pretty interesting
from a legal perspective.
I think my title is better than theirs,
but reasonable minds can differ,
and reasonable robots can differ too.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Oh... (laughs)
Well, this one I'd have
a hard time making.
"Bill Cosby Is Innocent, Part Two."
Now, putting aside that I'd have to make
a part one on that.
(sighs) Just because Bill
Cosby was released from jail
does not, by any means, make him innocent
in any way whatsoever.
In fact, the overwhelming
evidence is that he was guilty
of the crimes at issue.
But look, the criminal justice system
is about protecting our rights
as much as it is punishing
the people who offend
and commit these crimes.
I'm not gonna make that video
about Bill Cosby being innocent.
I'm sure there are some other
people out there that could.
It's not for me.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And speaking of which,
"Donald Trump Is Not Racist."
Again, you know, this channel
is about presenting both sides
and presenting facts as facts
when they're sort of objectively correct.
That being said, (sighs)
I'd have a hard time making that argument.
I'm not saying I can't. (chuckles)
I'm not saying it's impossible.
I'm just not sure that I
wanna spend a whole lotta time
and effort trying to make that argument.
(upbeat instrumental music)
So here's an interesting one.
"NYC Journalist Arrested for Filming
"the Arrest of Protesters."
I can't remember the last time
a New York City journalist
was arrested filming the protesters.
It definitely happened
a bunch this summer.
It'll happen again.
So maybe I'll keep that in my back pocket
for the next time it happens
'cause it's gonna happen again.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Again with Bill Cosby.
"Bill Cosby Gives his Kids Alcohol."
I mean, poor Theo.
But yeah, I'm not sure that there's much
of a legal issue there.
And yeah, I don't...
Let's not do that.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And speaking of which, "The
Memes That Freed Bill Cosby."
I'm not sure what exactly those memes are.
I probably could find
some Fifth Amended memes,
and I could use those memes to explain
why Bill Cosby went free.
That's a great idea for a video.
(chuckles) Yeah, I don't think in general
memes played a big part
in the vacating of Bill Cosby's sentence.
(upbeat instrumental music)
"#TheGroupChat: Sha'Carri
Richardson, Bill Cosby,
"Tabitha Brown versus Wendy
Williams and Rachel Nichols."
I don't even know what to do with that.
That doesn't make any sense.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Then this one comes out of left field.
"Stephen Jackson Defends Rachel Nichols."
Did he?
Is that true?
I'm not even sure, to be honest.
I will not be touching
one with a 10-foot pole.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And then one last Bill Cosby idea,
"The Bill Cosby Fun Game Bill:
Cosby Released From Prison."
I don't even wanna think about
what the Bill Cosby game would be.
I just know I don't want to play it.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And then finally we have a topic
that I will not be making on this channel.
"Talking About
Controversial Trans Topics."
(sighs) Yeah, I suppose I can
have my friend Harry Brewis
from Hbomberguy come on the channel
and we can have a discussion
about the legal implications
of all of the different things
surrounding those topics.
But I really don't think
the comment section
is going to be particularly civil
in a video entitled,
"Talking About
Controversial Trans Topics."
I'm gonna have to workshop
that one just a little bit.
Yeah, so maybe Skynet
isn't as close to fruition
as we thought
and the AI robot uprising is
not right around the corner.
But if robots do start invading,
you'll need to call the authorities
and you can save money on that call
by switching to today's
sponsor, Ting Mobile.
I personally switched to Ting Mobile
and saved literally hundreds
of dollars a month.,
and I'm not kidding.
Why? Because of this.
Yes, this is a real cell phone bill
that I got with my previous provider,
and it's why I personally
switched to Ting.
And Ting Mobile has three brand new plans
to make sure this never happens again.
All of Ting's plans have
unlimited talk and text
starting at just $10 per month,
add data for as little as $5 per gigabyte,
choose a set of data,
or get a full unlimited
plan for only $45 a month.
You can run as many AI
simulations as you want,
though this video will show
you that the AI simulations
are probably not worth all that much.
But switching plans is
actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone.
And the service is great
too because Ting partners
with several massive networks,
probably the very same one
that you're using right now,
but at a huge discount.
They literally use the
exact same infrastructure.
Now, actually, I can't
tell you which ones,
because I always respect contracts
and non-discloser agreements,
but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all.
And if you're around wifi all the time,
like you're working from home,
you have the flexibility
to save hundreds of dollars
using Ting's flex plan
like you always have,
or now you just have the possibility
of an unlimited version as well.
So if you want unlimited,
you can go absolutely crazy.
And it's incredibly easy
to transfer service.
You just simply order a Ting SIM card,
pop it in, and set it up.
No phone calls required. It's like magic.
But if you do wanna talk to Ting,
you can call them up and immediately talk
to a real human being
or use chat or discord.
You'll talk to a real
human, not an AI robot,
with virtually no wait times.
So if you would like to give Ting a try,
LegalEagles will get a $25 service credit
that could cover two months of service.
All you have to do is just
click on the link below
and give it a try.
Or you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
Just click on that link below.
Plus, it really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
check out this playlist
with all of my legal meme
reviews and lawyer jokes.
So remember, click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.